he was standing in front of you right  now what would you say to him you  stopped I'll say your loser you're a  quitter that's all I don't like quitters  he quit then you are trash  you would say that I would say I would  say that the best thing you should have  dunked it you can talk to us this whole  series I'm not gonna forgive that out of  my face um take some responsibility why  did you do what you did  I would have to thank him for the good  times we have with him but I might have  to you know remind him about them  playoffs versus Atlanta man what's in  game seven nothing  you give them a silent treatment yeah oh  no I just told him he's a good ball  player got a lot of potential he's just  gotta find it